[Music]
hello and welcome now every single one
of us has a responsibility to tackle the
climate emergency businesses and
governments have a significant role to
play in driving the positive change we
need
and as they look to make that change
happen they may find answers in some
unexpected places
we're talking today about what
businesses can learn from space and why
the space race may provide important
lessons for the race to net zero
joining me to discuss this are zubin
randaria esg leader at pwc uk
tania sinclair policy director uk and
ireland at chargepoint and libby jackson
human exploration program manager at the
uk space agency
well it's great to have you all here
today and i wanted to ask you about
the 1960s with the space race and how it
relates to us today in tackling climate
change and also the race to net zero
let's start off with you
when you look back the space race the
late 1950s 1960s were an amazing time in
space exploration
the world went from having never put
anything into space in the late 1950s
the first satellite flew in 1957 to
first human in space in 1961.
less than a decade later we've gone from
that very first human space flight to
landing humans on the moon
and in order to do that we had to
develop an entire industry we had to
work out how to take computers from the
size of rooms and shrink them into
shoeboxes we had to work out how you
could communicate with people in space
how you could keep them alive in space
and all of that was done in a background
of two countries competing
to prove that they were better than the
other it was the united states and the
soviet union
but that race has led to an industry
that we all rely on every single day
today we have seen innovations come into
our everyday lives in form
of materials uh in in applications here
we have loads and loads of things that
come from the space industry and today
it's in an industry of collaboration
yeah certainly in my industry in
electric car charging the parallels are
really clear actually even though there
are decades between the space race and
what we're doing today you know talking
about starting an industry from scratch
15 years ago there weren't really
electric cars and there was no electric
car charging industry and now there are
dozens of companies so many of them here
in the uk who are scale-ups and really
kind of growing very quickly all with
the ambition to provide enough charging
infrastructure so that people feel ready
to get into electric cars and why is
that so important because we have a net
zero
target to meet and a huge part of that
is the decarbonization of transport so
it's really important that we take those
lessons and we understand how to do
things quickly innovate go from uh
design to commercialization really
really quickly because we don't have the
luxury of time when it comes to dealing
with net zero
we talk about a challenge and the the
space race was a phenomenal challenge
wasn't it in 10 years what was achieved
but when we think about net zero we've
got 10 years
to halve global emissions to reduce
global warming by one and a half degrees
otherwise the scientists tell us there
will be pretty bad implications for the
planet and therefore whilst the space
race was a race between two superpowers
for national prestige
this is a challenge on a completely
different order this is a planetary
challenge this isn't one that can be
restricted to individual
companies organizations countries this
is one where the planet needs to solve
it together olivia you talked about
america and at the time
of the space phase president kennedy he
said he wanted to put a man on the moon
and he publicly stated that do you think
that was what made it happen and is that
where we're going with net zero i think
when you look back in history what
happened that there were various things
there was that um challenge and when
when kennedy said that
you have to remember the americans had
one human um alan shepard had been in
space for 15 minutes it was crazy to
think that that could be done yeah i
think the question of political will is
a really interesting one because
certainly in my field in the mobility
and decarbonization of transport you
have a lot of politicians all over the
world making really big commitments that
they want to see the end of petrol and
diesel vehicles you know here in the uk
the date is 20 30 after which you won't
be able to buy a new petrol or diesel
car or van
however there's
really noble intentions that politicians
set those targets for but it almost kind
of takes us off the hook in a way
because you know like you were saying
that there's a lot of uh individual
responsibility when it comes to
achieving that zero we all have our role
to play and so
politicians can set targets but you know
we all have to be collectively part of
the the effort to meet them the the key
thing is to follow through and execute
on those commitments and not all of the
solutions are there there needs to be
further innovations for example to
deliver on what needs to happen which we
don't know today a bit like when kennedy
made that statement necessity is the
mother of invention we saw it then we
we've seen it now and we will see it
with with the race to net zero if
everybody um comes together well i think
innovation is a key word here because
the space race was a breakthrough for
innovation do you think
it should be a key word for net zero
yes absolutely although innovation needs
skills it needs the pipeline of people
and ideas going into it in order to
develop that innovation especially here
in the uk you know the good thing about
ideas is that they can be global but you
know here we have a real opportunity for
kids who are in school now to be able to
be inspired by the challenge of net zero
and really go into careers that you know
can practically deliver that innovation
uh so we're there by 2050. so i think
there's been a phenomenal amount of
innovation you know if you only look
back
seven eight years 2013 there's about
half a billion dollars of investment in
climate tech from the venture capital
industry one ford six years and the 16
billion dollars now that's a rate of
growth three times as much as has gone
into artificial intelligence which we
see all around us
but when you look in aggregate it's
still a drop in the ocean compared with
the innovation that's needed to solve
such a global problem and we've seen so
much progression you know in ev charging
for cars you know and solar charging and
stuff like that but there's still so
much more that needs to be done that we
don't know today and we need to solve a
very big problem together collectively
and collaborate and therefore that's
going to drive a significant amount of
innovation going forward so i suppose
it's about greater collaboration the
communication between both sides i think
this is one area where business can
really learn from not just space but
science you know science is based upon
you know building upon the shoulders of
others what has gone before and for
business
it by and large it's a tendency to
compete to do things proprietary to keep
things to yourself to create value for
your own organization shareholders
here is a problem which can only be sold
if organizations governance governments
non-governmental organizations
collaborate to solve
a planetary problem this isn't a
shareholder problem or a company problem
and therefore this is one thing where
this will only get solved through
collaboration
yeah i agree with that but there's also
a really interesting other angle to that
which is the competition also can
accelerate the pace of change so you see
it in the car industry at the moment a
lot of car companies really driven by
tesla at the forefront are in a race
competing with one another to deliver
electric cars and vans and trucks as
quickly as possible and that competition
is really helping move our market
forward i think more quickly than it
otherwise would have but yes there's
also examples of collaboration going on
in that space because a lot of those
companies are working together
in a way they've never done before
whether it's on battery technology or
software to actually bring those cars
that might have different badges on them
but actually have the same technology
underneath a bit that goes back to what
you're saying about russia and america i
was about to say you bring it together
now that the the whole space industry
grew and the technology that we have
grew out of the second world war the
rockets that we all rely on to put all
these satellites and spacecraft in space
that we all rely on every single day
that technology came out of the second
world war you then had the cold war and
america and the soviet union you know
racing each other to get to the moon
but after that
they came together they opened up to the
rest of the world and we built the
international space station and that has
been a collaboration of america canada
russia japan countries across europe
today including the uk
um working together to build this
amazing unique laboratory so where does
all this investment come from how do we
pay for this
it's a really interesting question
because there is a significant amount of
capital around the world that is looking
for a home and as we think about the
shift in capital as investors big
pension funds insurance companies
sovereign wealth funds are looking to
deploy their their capital to inform
increasingly they're looking for clean
responsible
well-run companies and we see that's the
opportunity if you can organize your
business so that you can demonstrate how
clean it is then you're going to attract
capital it's interesting in just in the
uk
there's long-term investors who invest
in infrastructure and the uk needs about
40 billion a year invested in
low-carbon digital infrastructure about
half of that
is accessible to pension funds people
who are very patient who can invest for
the long term but half of that is high
risk stuff the big challenge then is to
de-risk that investment to develop it
out of the lab commercialize it and take
it into what we see in for example
electric vehicles today rather than 15
years ago then it's available available
to be investible by long-term capital
yeah in the electric vehicle sector the
assumption is that governments have to
seed or at least start to fund the
sector in order to make it sustainable
over the last decade the government has
funded uh every new purchase of an
electric car
from it used to be five thousand pounds
now it's around two thousand pounds and
that's not necessary anymore uh because
these businesses are growing and they're
sustainable in their own right the
company that i work for went public this
year listed on the new york stock
exchange you know there's a demand and
an interest in wanting to invest in
these kinds of companies and then drive
the technology forward that way
so how do you bring people along
into this race to net zero how do you
inspire them to think yeah we're going
to jump on this bandwagon that's
something where i think space and human
space flight plays its part uh in the
astronauts always come back from space
and are able to share first-hand seeing
our planet our beautiful very delicate
planet in this amazing blackness of
space with this thin teeny tiny delicate
atmosphere and it's stories like that i
think that open people's eyes where we
have a part to play in in highlighting
how important our planet is how unique
it is in the as far as we know entire
universe at the minute and so that's
somewhere where i think space can be
there we also play our part in in
looking at how all this is going to
happen to monitor the earth to make sure
that we are understanding all of these
things we have to have data and of all
the data that we need half of it can
only be got from space i think this is a
really interesting one because in
business it's not one where business has
to convince
our people to come along it's working
the other way around you know it's our
people who are saying you know this is
the world that i want to live in an
environment i want to live in a planet i
want to live in a society i want to live
in and
people wanting business to catch up and
i think there's a lot of pressure from
younger people in particular in terms of
the organizations that they want to work
for the values that they associate with
those organizations and selecting those
organizations that they want to
participate in their careers with i
think this ties in nicely with the word
legacy here because the space race it
created a legacy it had a massive impact
do you think there's going to be a huge
legacy with net zero for our children
it's it's
our job
um to leave a an or a planet that is fit
for our children
and we have a very very short space of
time it feels like a long time people
talk about 2050 2050 is going to be with
us quite soon we've got 10 years to half
global admissions and 10 years was the
time which we're amazed that we sent a
man to the moon i think that if we can
talk to nets talk to our our next
generation about net zero being a
problem of the present even though we've
set ourselves a nice convenient far away
target then it's really something that
kind of will help the next generation
want to solve a problem because it's a
problem of today and it's a problem that
will be in our lifetimes but very much
part of theirs as well well this has
been a brilliant and wide-ranging
conversation and i've enjoyed every
minute of it i really want to thank our
panelists for taking part in sharing so
much insight into a topic that will
shape all of our lives in the years to
come
i hope you've enjoyed watching this has
been one of a series of five episodes
all exploring how the biggest challenges
facing business will be better solved
together